a white house press secretary jenn saki
has tested positive for covid and of
course the question was well
when was she with joe biden and what's
going on and it actually turns out that
she hasn't been around joe biden for a
little bit and is not on joe biden's
current trip to europe apparently
because many in her family had tested
positive so here's the report from cnn
saki test positive for covid last saw
biden tuesday
white house press secretary jensaki who
dropped off president joe biden's
international trip shortly before he
departed has tested positive for
coronavirus after members of her
household did sake said she last saw
biden tuesday outside while masked
before the president departed for rome
for the group of 20 summit and that she
tested negative several times in between
saki said she was disclosing the
positive test result quote out of an
abundance of transparency adding she
experienced mild symptoms and is working
remotely it's unlikely saki could have
infected biden with covid19 several
physicians told cnn sunday based on the
timeline of misaki's testing negative
for multiple days following her last
encounter with biden which was also
outside and masked therefore very low
risk in and of itself dr liana wen a cnn
medical analyst and former baltimore
city health commissioner said in an
email
the white house announced thursday sake
would no longer join biden on his trip
abroad for the at least the first few
days citing a family emergency
white house deputy press secretary
karine jean-pierre instead traveled with
the president jensaki put out a
statement about this
where she said on wednesday in
coordination with senior leadership at
the white house and the medical team i
made the decision
not to travel with the four on the
foreign trip with the president due to a
family emergency which was members of my
household testing positive for covid19
since then i have quarantined and tested
negative via pcr for covet on wednesday
thursday friday and saturday however
today i tested positive for covet while
i have not had close contact in person
with the president or senior members of
the white house staff since wednesday
and tested negative for four days after
that last contact i am disclosing
today's positive test out of an
abundance of transparency i last saw the
president on tuesday when we sat outside
more than six feet apart and wore masks
thanks to the vaccine i have only
experienced mild symptoms which has
enabled me to continue working from home
i plan to return to work in person at
the conclusion of the 10-day quarantine
following a negative rapid test which is
an additional white house requirement
beyond cdc guidance taken out of an
abundance of caution so she's vaccinated
so is joe biden outside masks two
vaccinated people transmission risk is
almost zero i say not i don't say zero
because strange things happen when you
have bell curve distributions of things
and unexplainable things happen
incredibly unlikely that joe biden would
get coveted in this case um she
correctly assesses
her risk is lower and her risk of a
serious case is lower because she's
vaccinated that's true now there are
people opportunists and just ignorant
people who will see this and once again
much like with the death of colin powell
say this is proof that the vaccines
don't work and of course any one
anecdote doesn't tell us much about at a
population level what does and doesn't
work about vaccines the fact that colin
powell died despite being vaccinated
given that he was 84 and
immunocompromised in more than one way
doesn't really tell us anything about
the effect at a population level of
vaccination in much the same way when
gensake says thanks to the vaccine i
have mild symptoms
that's not really an empirical statement
statistically speaking she's likely to
have fewer symptoms thanks to being
vaccinated any individual though
it's harder to make such a statement but
her general assessment is correct by
being vaccinated
she's at lower risk for a serious case
and unfortunately there are many people
who either don't understand the science
or don't want to understand it because
they have preconceived notions or
desires about what they believe the
vaccine to do
where they will say what's the point of
getting vaccinated saki was vaccinated
and she got it well she's she's working
at home and she seems to feel mostly
okay so that's the latest
very unlikely that joe biden um
could have
received the virus or uh
been what's the word that she would have
spread the virus to joe biden
in the situation that was described
particularly when she continued testing
negative for several days
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 off and free shipping when you go
to 4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video